[ __ ]
okay we're gonna do a review of the
predator yes another movie review yeah
this one's kind of a gimme you know
there's lots of reviews on the predator
but we're gonna do a little bit
differently I think the the copy that I
have is the ultimate hunter edition
blu-ray which I can't believe it's
really called that but it is right yeah
I almost didn't buy this edition because
it was getting dinged in reviews people
complain about there's one scene you
know where Carl brothers face kind of
looks pretty airbrushed but I'm but I'm
glad I got it because that's only for a
second there really yeah I noticed it
like and that was like early on in the
movie like this seems like it's even
before they go out in the jungle like
when there is deaf is talking just in
the during the brief and he yeah he
looks a little waxy like they over
airbrushed yeah over digitized his face
but other than that after that I didn't
notice that any mind now look great
after that so I don't know I think it
was I think it's nitpicking you know
some guys have to have total perfection
and evidently there is no real perfect
copy of this blu-ray although this one
looks great I think it looks great
yeah and they're giving it away you can
get it for about five bucks delivered
yeah the eBay yeah so I'm glad to I'm
glad to get it but I love the predator I
saw the predator probably about three
times in the theater when it first came
out yeah he's not in Brazil right the
first time I saw it I saw it in Brazil
and it was funny because behind me were
some Brazilian girls that came in they
were probably out 25 26 maybe bit a
little bit younger and they were
illiterate they they couldn't read the
subtitle subtitles yeah and they came in
late so they didn't actually see the the
spaceship scene right where that I
should have forgotten that there was a
spaceship scene at the beginning yeah
and they didn't know this was a monster
movie so they're just watching what they
think is an army movie and you know
they're they're commenting like god man
look at his arms you know man he's hot
looks like an Indian you know that kind
of stuff
and they you know all sorts negra v they
were looking at its arms and everyone
like home
and then finally you know when they
showed the Predators hands you know the
scene where you first see his hand in
the thermal vision where it's got the
scorpion in its hand yeah they're like
the [ __ ] is this and then finally when
they realize it's like a monster movie
you know they're like oh you know they
got real quiet back there when the
predator finally took its mask off those
girls lost it it was funny you know this
hilarious the cold is totally getting
into this movie the coolest thing that I
that I always liked about predator cuz
I'm not like I'm not a huge action movie
fan or anything like that but one of the
coolest things about predator and I know
this is kind of a weird thing to say but
it's almost kind of like at the same
time that it's a super over-the-top
action movie there's just like [ __ ]
guys shooting guns like that but at the
same time as a horror film it's actually
very restrained yes because when we
watched it the other day I had actually
forgotten how long it took yeah for them
to actually show them up they really
don't show the monster hardly at all
until the end and I thought that was
really cool and honestly I can't
remember cuz I know we watched the
trailer and I can't remember exactly
what was in the trailer but other than
that brief couple seconds at the
beginning when they show the spaceship
and everything like that
all the trailer and all the poster and
everything like that it didn't say that
it was a monster room no I mean the
poster just had Arnold Schwarzenegger
looking buff like he does with a gun or
whatever so you just thought it was like
an action like an army movie I went to
it having seen terminator
yeah first and I kind of saw the
digitized thing and the and the military
you know the digitized look of the movie
poster with military clothing I thought
it was gonna be something like
Terminator right yeah you know but then
when I got into it it was an army movie
yes and it was a damn good army in fact
this movie was one of the influences
that influenced me into joining the army
infantry yeah become an airborne and it
wasn't just me a lot of other guys in my
patellae as my career loved this movie
one of them in particular actually had a
predator tattoo and it looked really
cool yes I was just like Top Gun babe it
was like top a lot of people who I
wanted to go into the Air Force and it's
as far as a military movie you know I've
analyzed it over and over again over the
years and it
it's accurate for the time yeah they had
a lot of military guys that were and
some of the people in the cast half of
our ex-felons half him we're ex-military
Jesse the body was ex-seal the guy who
played Pancho was X infantry from
Vietnam wasn't there another one that
was ex-military and I'm not sure Carl
would think Carl was but they did have a
military advisor yeah in charge they
usually do on those they write things
down the only thing the the only thing
that was kind of inaccurate to me they
jumps out is that none of them were
carrying ammo pouches and I didn't even
notice that until you brought it up and
then I was like oh yeah the really shot
up the whole [ __ ] jungle
the reason being is that in that era the
L CER load carrying equipment that we
used was like suspenders on a belt and
on that belt you hung your canteens a
thing called but pack which that sounds
kind of nasty it's a little it's a
little pack in the middle of your waist
that you usually carry like your poncho
and your and this nylon blanket or maybe
a day's worth of MREs you know and at
the front on the belt the suspenders
connected to ammo pouches where you kept
magazines Mississippi it's called cliffs
yeah and each one would carry three m16
magazines you know on either side and
what that did was is with that load
carrying system that we had back then it
put on everything around the waist so it
made everyone look kind of short and
dumpy and they're not gonna take these
you know bags they're not gonna take
these like super buffed out alpha males
in this and make it like that it's
creative
yeah so they you know they they're not
carrying any ammo pouches but they sure
as hell are shooting a bunch of [ __ ]
ammo yeah yeah well and I love to you
that Jesse Ventura who was in this movie
and he uses that minigun right yeah and
it's like it's funny because that he
will shoot that minigun just forever and
yeah like you're saying it would run out
of ammo in like a second well maybe not
just about depends on how much he could
carry well first of all you have to have
some kind of electrical power source to
power it yeah
it's not gas-operated it's electrical so
the electrical power system to run that
gun is running up at Jessie's legs yeah
you know they've routed it in a certain
way so you know when they show him
firing they're hiding the fact that
they've got an electrical cord power in
the thing somewhere else in that
backpack that he had you could probably
carry 500 rounds belt it and you'd burn
that up out of a mini gun prob about you
know maybe 10 seconds probably if they
held the trigger down fires awful fast
I've never fired a minigun but all that
other stuff they're showing off fired
most of those weapons the 40-millimeter
grenade launchers you know in the m203
even though that's not a real m203
they're showered it's it's actually a
replica I've never fired an mp5 those
mp5 submachine guns like Carl Brothers
has and poncho ass that was actually a
civilian semi-auto version that they cut
the barrel down off and converted it
into full auto to make it a machine gun
some crucial differences in the true
military version the military version
has a flash suppressor on it and it also
has a little toggle lover for the
magazine release instead of the push
button it's complicated one of the
weapons I cared for the year was the m60
and you remember what's-his-name Mac
Mac's carrying the m60 III which is like
the short commando version that the
marine recon carried for for a little
while but no it's a good movie it's good
movie probably boring people well if the
thing is it's like you know yeah it's
they did try to get some [ __ ] accurate
but yeah you know if you're gonna make a
good monster movie you can't have
everything be totally accurate just like
I mean like what was another thing that
we were saying before about how the
predator has you know heat vision he can
yeah and how Arnold Schwarzenegger you
know he kind of hides from him by
getting in the mud right that was work I
don't think it worked for a few seconds
now your body heat would heat the body
up to your body temperature like you'd
see the differences in temperatures you
know just a half a degree I think and we
were talking about this we were watching
it is that the first time I saw a
predator and like when they showed the
monster and stuff like that I flake
flipped the [ __ ] out when he took his
helmet off because I didn't realize that
was a helmet
yeah well because you wouldn't know he's
an alien right right and people are
gonna laugh at me too but it's like the
first time when I saw Star Wars when I
was a kid yeah I thought the
stormtroopers were just like robots
so like when so when Han and Lou like
took one of them like what the [ __ ] yeah
well I'll tell you what that predator
that monster that alien mask of the
outfit I guess you what I'm trying to
say that really set the standards for
for special effects that was up there
with alien from alien wanan that's still
nowadays and this movie was made in 1986
still looks good
it still looks fantastic I mean it that
looks like a real monster yeah it does
it looks a lot to me yeah and I mean I
can't even imagine it looks better in
predator 1 than it does in predator 2
and yeah and in Predators yeah the third
one won't even know I like predators I
can't let them - yeah I did - but now in
in the third one some they did actually
use some practical effects right it
wasn't
oh yeah GI yeah I think was mostly
practical effects they did use some CG
and evidently the predator that they
used one of them you know one of the
Predators that they used in predators
was made from the same mold as the
original okay yeah it doesn't quite look
as real to me yeah it looks a little
rubbery but the monster in the first
movie does not look rubbery at all like
yeah it looks like and it's weird
because I'm assuming like for his
mandibles and stuff like that I mean
they used what like hydraulics and [ __ ]
like that
cables cables and it does not look like
it doesn't know it doesn't look anything
like that yeah and that guy that played
the predator knew how to move in that
thing when he was a dancer well yeah he
was like a ballet dancer it looked like
a real creep and he was super tall - he
was like seven seven feet tall so yeah
and unfortunately he passed away just a
few years 1991 yeah yeah yeah he had a
blood transfusion and he got aids from a
blood stream blood transfusion and yes
in the movie at the very end when they
finally get to the choppa yeah the tall
the the the black guy fly the chopper is
the guy that plays in the bread
so they felt bad that you weren't able
to see his face for the whole movie so
they gave him a little bit gave him a
little yes yeah but yeah but you but you
can really tell and I'm really and I'm
glad that they got somebody that with
that kind of physicality yeah to play
that role because it really comes across
right this kind of alien like the way he
moves and stuff like that it's very very
fit very alien kind of for me everything
about the the military equipment the
military uniforms you know to me that
just kind of hit home all the pants you
know like I had those pants and those
jackets when I was in the service I had
those boots those green jungle boots I
was like one of the last batch of guys
that was allowed to wear those until
they finally turned those of green
jungle boots into the black versions so
they all that stuff kind of reminiscent
to me yeah you know and Arnold
Schwarzenegger played Dutch and one of
the things that I thought was kind of
into an interesting little detail he's
wearing regular BDU pants but he's
wearing this like coyote tan jacket like
a shirt yeah and you could see that it
zips right and his buddy Poncho's
wearing that same thing it's almost like
hero worship he's wearing that exact
same outfit the other guys are just
wearing right pretty much regular stuff
what's his name weathers his character's
name was Dylan Dylan yeah that's right
he's wearing like just OD green you know
just look cool kid oh yeah I liked it it
looks like the shirt and a little cutoff
vest that he had it looked like
something he got from a sporting goods
store which that's about right you know
when we were in service not everything
that we wore was milspec was an issue
we're when you're in the field you're
allowed to wear stuff that you buy to
you know within certain parameters so
you know you buy you know better sets of
boots you know so it's funny cuz you go
online and I hear these guys you know
they're looking at all this uniform
stuff to play like paintball and airsoft
and they're going well they're going
well that's not in there collecting guns
you know assault rifles and they're
trying to get rigs together and well
that's not true milspec that's not
[ __ ] when we were in the army didn't
we we didn't use you know that's not
flame retardant that didn't matter to us
when you're in the military if you were
in the infantry you caught on fire
that's because you were burning to death
in a helicopter crash flame retardant
uniform wasn't gonna save you from three
Gallants burning jet fuel what do you
think it was about cuz I mean the thing
is the 80s a lot of kind of monster
movies came out in the 80s like some of
them are really good a lot of action
movies came out mateys but there's
something really kind of I don't know
there's something just really special
about predator like I said it's not
usually a genre that I like all that
much you know you want to know why it's
it student there's something about it
that's really because it's like
lightning in a bottle honestly because
it was a it was a realistic army movie
out of the middle of nowhere threw a
left curve that there was an alien it
became a harmony yeah there was an alien
in it that happened to be in a Central
American country hunting soldiers in a
war-torn area which says wow where'd
that come from
and it was believable yeah mostly when
you saw the the alien the creature
effects you're like yeah that looks like
a real creepy yeah if it and now here's
a couple of here's some interesting
trivia about this moon now predator was
the one that was written by two guys and
they just slipped it under someone's
door yes studio right yeah they had
never written they had never really
written a script that got produced or
anything like that they sure they just
kind of happen to get on the lot and
they said hey put it under this guy's
office door right but I don't think they
actually came up with this idea per se
because there was another movie that had
come out a few years before that I saw
it I was a kid there was a lot like it
called without warning yeah yeah yeah
and it was more like a teen slasher
movie teenagers the same guy that played
the predator was in that that's right
yeah that's right Kevin Peter Hall like
this Essenza
and it was just an alien hunting
teenagers yeah in a cabin it was nowhere
near as cool as predator well the thing
is I think it's the same kind of well I
think the two guys might have seen that
movie and then they're like okay well if
there was an alien that was hunting
humans yeah it wouldn't be Nate it
wouldn't right yeah right so that would
be more of a conflict because teenagers
yeah anybody can kill teen a big deal in
that movie without warning was kind of
cool because the alien didn't have I
don't remember him ever you
any technology like ray guns he had
these little octagonal or pentagonal
shaped creatures that he would throw and
when they'd hit you
they had suction cups on them and then
they had tentacles that would come out
and pierce through your skin and wrap
and wrap around your ribcage and in the
center of it a head little teeth and it
started not like that from the 50s and I
can't remember the name of it they did
it on Mystery Science Theater I think
Peter Graves was in it I want to say but
it was the same kind of thing but it was
kind of like invasion that more like
invasion of the Body Snatchers but the
aliens had these little things that kind
of look like bats are like octagonal
bats or sent there trapezoidal I need to
see this and they would kind of suck to
the back of your neck and then turn you
into like a zombie kind of would take
over your personality or whatever so you
know it's an idea that's kind of out
there but I can see how you could take
that idea and improve and improve upon
it because like I said it's more of a
challenge if it's a bunch of like army
guys yeah like top tier right military
dudes fighting against an alien yet an
alien if they're doing it for sport
obviously they would want the challenge
yeah you know another thing that some
people have questioned is whether or not
Arnold Schwarzenegger and his crew were
military and they weren't they actually
weren't active military they were by
today's standards they would be called
contractors yeah back in the day they
call them mercenaries but today you call
them couple Carl Weathers was he worked
for the CIA right and yeah just putting
they put together like a group of elite
people to go in there yeah and there was
legal issues too because to this day you
can't use contractors in combat right
all right now just because you kill
people doesn't mean that that's combat
you notice that combat is a mission
where you go out specifically to destroy
an enemy unit yeah that's not what they
were there for they were there to rescue
some people who have gotten captured if
you kill someone in the act of rescuing
someone that's not cut out so you can
use contractors to like a loophole yeah
all right but it turns out the CIA and
they weren't the first ones to be sent
you find out they find out that Special
Forces went first and they got their
asses handed to me all got skinned by
the predator all right
so they send in these contractors that's
why they're in civilian clothes men show
up in there where and whatever they want
to wear and they're doing what
they want to do and they're doing an
operation other than war in a country
that they haven't waged war gets right
and buh-buh-buh-buh-buh which used to
happen and still happens so they weren't
actually active military they were
contractors yeah but I don't know I feel
like if anybody else had been in it if
it had come out of different I just
don't think it would have worked but I
think it worked because one the ensemble
cast was so good like I liked that they
were all like all the characters were
kind of bigger than life and they were
all kind of over the top but not in an
unbelievable way yeah and I like that
they kind of characterized them without
too much backstory they didn't really
give each of them too much backstory but
they each had a distinct personality the
same across like without too much
they're working they're a group of
battle-hardened veterans doing a rescue
mission they were working together as a
team it was all kind of click and then
you were just like along for the ride
and they were all good guys they were
comic Matic including call you know
called weathers the CIA guy he was cool
too you know it was very different from
say predator 2 in predator 2 the main
characters I really didn't care about
him I think there didn't I don't think
they had too many redeeming qualities
they didn't they weren't really heroic
to me they're [ __ ] heads or not super
charismatic yeah annoying I think the
movie suffered too and I think that some
reviews of this even pointed it out at
the time that it's like predator really
worked because it was like in the jungle
and you can really see and it was like
camouflage when you put predator in LA
which he was in the city wasn't it don't
get the isolation yeah you don't get the
isolation kind of thing it's like oh
it's a monster running around los zetas
there's so many movies set in Los
Angeles I'd like to thank the thing
worked because the isolation of that's
like the scariest aspect and to me that
seemed like the scariest aspect of
predator to me is that one for a long
time you didn't know what it was that
was ever they didn't you know and if
they were scared shitless then you
better be scared shitless because
they're like battle-hardened veterans
yeah and they were going what is this
are these guys they work on whether
these sappers coming after us you know
it's a sapper is an engine a combat
engineer but you know they use traps and
they can defenses and things so that was
kind of a logical conclusion that maybe
a couple of sappers code that we're
doing this to them but then the Scout
Billy who I think he kind of look like
an American Native American Indian which
that's kind of cool because then you
have an Indian scout which is like in
the army traditions those are the best
Scouts to have or Indian scouts you know
Special Forces Indian scout and he's
like thinking that this might be some
kind of a supernatural force he's given
the clue into that right that something
wasn't right that this wasn't either
this ain't no man yeah you know so he
knew something was wrong you know and
then finally when they see it you know
this thing they're just saying it's this
thing they didn't they didn't know if it
was an alien or not yeah yeah which i
think is one of the best things about
the MU because like I said it took so
long yeah and you didn't know what it
was and they didn't know what it was and
they didn't show it for ever like it was
pretty much like the what the like the
last third of the movie I think it
wasn't until you got down to the very
last man Dutch you know play bars Arnold
Arnold Schwarzenegger I think he was the
one to find when he finally saw its face
I think he realized that it was an alien
yes because I don't think they knew that
no prior to that because you wouldn't
well you wouldn't jump to that
conclusion if you were in that satchel I
think they thought it was a man of some
kind of camouflage cuz they'd say you
know it's some kind of camouflage I saw
one of them camouflaged I saw its eyes
and then they disappeared yeah and it
was weird somebody like experimenting
with some like top-secret [ __ ] like word
that you were under some kind of like
someone was experimenting yeah which you
can kind of do that yes they with a
mirror yeah if you hold a mirror the
right way and angle it just the right
way in a jungle type environment you
will seem to disappear yeah until you go
around the side beside it and another
thing like I said one of the things that
made this work is one because the
monster looked so badass yeah if they
had left it so long with like all this
build up and build up and then the
monster sucked yeah so it really had to
they really had to make in originally
the month the monster did suck it did
yes stop the movie went back and got
another monster and inserted it
yeah because didn't know this point they
shot a lot of the movie right yeah and
then they had to go back and do all the
monsters and if
get the because we have the blu-ray and
if you look at some of the extra [ __ ]
yeah they show some of the stuff that
they filmed with the original monster oh
yeah it didn't look good and it looks
really goofy yeah I mean the behind her
would have failed yeah with that first
money because if you if they had had all
this build-up all these all these bad SD
is being scared for the whole movie and
then like the last third of the movie
they shows movies like through yeah
you'd have been like [ __ ] that yeah it
didn't look bad it just didn't look
anywhere near as good as yeah that's the
predator because I mean can you but like
I think on the other any other film any
other movie probably would have left
that monster yeah yeah no but I likes it
they well what they did they shot most
of the movie and then when they were
watching it back like worth day editing
of like an early cut of it or something
like how the head move the head move did
it Bob yeah it's like a turkey or a
little dog head turkey dog it was not
intimidating looking at all no and
that's what I mean if somebody took the
mask off and his face kind of looked
like the front end of a [ __ ] of a
scorpion and and and I yeah that's why
they showed it grab a scorpion it was
kind of kind of yeah it looks like it to
your kid had a baby with the scorpions
at Ace yeah or something they tried to
suggest a scorpion type quality on it
when it picked up that scorpion yeah its
face reminded me of the mandibles on a
scorpion but its skin was kind of like a
cross between a frog and a yeah
alligator yeah it was like amphibian
baby in yeah and then it had like those
cool but now where the the dreadlocks
that it had were them was that it's hair
is that like a headdress it's just one
big old hair look like one big hair on a
ball socket mystic imagine what their
barber shops must look like on our
planet
this is the kind of stupid [ __ ] like
last night we were watching we like
what's it
Oliver Harper that British guy that does
all those movie or the yeah he does we
were watching some of his movie reviews
last night and we were watching a review
of Superman the movie and they showed
that scene where that's actually
Superman 2 wasn't it yeah we're Saad or
whoever
or one of the bad guys like for a
Superman against the car and I just and
I thought to myself I was like man ki
imagine having to call your car
insurance company and saying that
Superman's ass broke your would they
even cover that yeah yeah matter of fact
that Oliver Harper he's one of the guys
that you want to see if you wanted like
a real straight formalized review he
does a lot of them I find them to be
that they're kind of boring there's lots
of those ours are kind of personalized
reviews yeah yeah yeah almost like a
real show yeah not like not like which
is just - idiot yeah but actually I just
wanted to stand up for predator and the
ultimate hunter edition it is a good
copy of it if you don't have anything
else yeah it's not like really nice yeah
I thought it looked really good there's
only just that one scene and it's only
for a few seconds we're like okay that's
what he's talking about him too so yeah
but that really didn't just didn't throw
me out of it no it's just a couple of
things only a couple of seconds that's
all so it's safe to get and I'll tell
you what on a good HDTV with a good
sound system it's fun to watch yeah it's
really good to watch I had a great time
watch Ida soundtrack second amazing yeah
it really takes me back to the other
than I would not recommend predator 2
however yeah we're seeing less scene but
it's not as a job you have to pay for it
a predators which is the third one I
actually like I did like predators I've
seen it about four times now in each
time I've watched that I've seen I pick
up more and I liked it better yeah cool
concept and like it is true to the
original in many ways it's close it's
it's not it's hard to top predator one
yeah it's just kind of like when they do
like a delayed sequel or when they
remake something from the 80s or
something like that you're not gonna get
the same charm you're not gonna run you
know what I mean it's not quite the same
experience because you could I know
what's common yeah that's another thing
about predators that you know it's just
kind of like any movie where now
everybody knows the
so it's like you can have you know it's
like Planet of the Apes you blow it up
you know it's like I wish that I could
see it without knowing no that was gonna
happen and the same thing with predator
I can't really remember because you know
I was I guess I just started high school
when it came out I think I saw it in the
theater I think I remember seeing
theater maybe I was in high school I
think I might have been at either a
junior or senior I was either in ninth
grade or 10th grade okay 87 year 87 I
was a senior yeah cuz I graduated in
1990 so I was either at ninth grade or
tenth for you but um amen look that
movie still holds up yeah it's I was
surprised at how how good it still
looked yeah it still looks really good I
mean it does not look cheesy in the
slightest and you sit there and eat
popcorn watch that man yeah I room yeah
so get the popcorn going and get to the
choppa okay so if you like our movie
reviews we're gonna be doing some more
pretty soon and also please remember to
go to our patreon page and give us a
couple bucks if you would or if you or
also if you go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast dot wordpress.com or
might be reversed I always forget
there's also a Pay Pal button on there
if you'd rather give a one-time donation
rather than a monthly donation so you
can do that too and I think that's about
it you have this movie review and
that'll do it for predator
[Music]